[Music]
thank you
it has been 10 years from the plan that
we had to have something that was of
this scale of a conference here in India
and seeing it in person in reality and
speaking at the conference here it is
amazing
[Music]
this is the first time the conference is
happening in person in India and there
are three reasons why I love this the
first is the amazing people the
community second are the amazing line of
speakers in this conference and the
third is the amazing organizers and
Volunteers in this conference they have
put their heart and soul into this
[Music]
and it's very interesting that in a
developer conference for a security talk
there was a lot of audience and you know
there were a lot of interaction after
the talk as well so which was very nice
and the confidence itself has been very
very uh pleasantly surprising for me
[Music]
it was an honor to be here I gave a talk
on creating a price forecast using long
short term memory networks and
tensorflow.js the goal was to give a
high level introduction into machine
learning artificial intelligence deep
learning build those from scratch in
JavaScript and build and train models to
predict stock prices in the browser
[Music]
and today I was discussing this kind of
security issues low level issues which
is not the same as in web applications
but the C plus plus level issues such as
type confusions that can be exploited
with zero day attacks and eventually
lead to a compromise of a lot of people
okay
and my talk today at jscons India was
about how we can use cognitive
psychology to better understand how
people read and interpret code and as a
result take away a few guidelines on how
to write code that is more readable to
others and to your future self
overall it was a fun experience I
definitely loved the crowd over here it
was definitely energetic and I loved the
way audience was engaging you know
raising your hands and just replying
back to whatever I was asking so overall
it was a great one
it is a overwhelming response because I
have never spoken at a bigger conference
and it's such a huge size of audience
and so I would say like the overall
experience was absolutely amazing
absolutely thrilled to be a part of the
diversity sponsor uh gives us the edge
trying to bring different people from
different backgrounds into the mix and
help us bridge that Gap and help build a
strong solid platform for the front end
world I don't think in India you get
these kind of conferences the kind of
content the networking opportunities the
exposure that people get here is simply
commendable and I wish all the best to
the organizers and everyone who's come
here
[Music]
this has been a fantastic experience
coming the excitement is so infectious
everyone around is just so happy to be
here and it really just fills my spirit
to believe that the future of JavaScript
the future of the web Community is in
really good hands this organizing crew
did such a fantastic job with this event
and all the attendees that I got to meet
they all had such great questions and so
much excitement in their eyes so I know
that the future of the web
looks really bright and positive
I came here all the way from Bulgaria
and Conference it's so well organized
and all the talks that they have seen so
far are deeply Technical and super
engaging so thank you for putting this
together and definitely enjoy the next
edition if you have the chance to
I think it went well and it's really
nice to be here at a new jsconf the
youngest jsconf in the family I was one
of the organizers of jsconf in Australia
we finished up a couple years ago it's
just really nice to be back in that same
sort of energy
[Music]
we also sponsored the event and I think
it was a very very good thing to do
because we had a lot of engaging
conversations we actually met Cloud
doing customers we also got a lot of
questions and a lot of inquiries about
cloudiness services and products and
offerings that we do and generally
there's a lot of people who are very
keen to learn more about you know
services such as cloudiness so overall
this event I think was a very very
successful one for
it's really awesome to be back to a JS
conf and I'm so happy I'm I'm very proud
of the legacy of this community it's
great to see it happen in India has it
it's been so much fun a little jet
lagged but I gave a talk about web
components and uh yeah I think it went
pretty okay most people didn't think I
was totally crazy and that was a that
was a good outcome
[Music]
great work done by the organizers as
well keeping the two trucks in parallel
and managing each and everything on time
I'll be really excited to come here next
year as well and my Personal Agenda is
you know contribute as much as I can to
the community and take the community to
the next level
[Music]
this was one of the best organized
conferences ever everything is
absolutely top from back to back the
people are amazing it's my first time in
India so I already see that people here
are much more outgoing they are reaching
out to you they're asking questions so
thanks so much for having me and well I
hope I will be here next year as well
[Music]
this is one of the best or I should say
the best conference so far I've attended
and more than like a family there are so
many of my friends so many familiar
faces which I could come across and the
vibe of Cheers conference is just
amazing and yeah I would like to come
again here so yeah thank you thank you
so much it was really amazing experience
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you